ja willkommen zur aktuellen
Themensendung im Seminar politische
Philosophie heute geht es um das Thema
macht und Politik und das Verhältnis
dieser beiden Begriffe und auch
Phänomene wir haben ein paar Fragen
welche Rolle spielt die Macht in der
politischen Kommunikation oder welche
Rolle sollte sie spielen wie wird macht
politisch und demokratisch erzeugt und
wie wird macht umgesetzt natürlich ist
macht ein seh problematisches Thema
macht kann häufig missbraucht werden und
darum soll es heute auch gehen macht und
Politik was kann man dazu sagen Politik
hat es immer mit Macht zu tun das ist
ganz klar häufig wird jedoch die These
vertreten dass Politik in nichts anderem
als in
Macht streben vielleicht auch
Machtmissbrauch machtinteresse besteht
und das ist sicherlich ein verkürzter
Begriff des
politischen Politik kann es auch mit
anderen Phänomen zu tun haben z.B
mit der Frage nach dem Gemeinwohl mit
der Frage nach Nachhaltigkeit und auch
mit Gerechtigkeit das ist auch ein
wichtiges Thema und dann mache ich da
auch einen Link
rein zu dieser Sendung wo es um
Gerechtigkeit
ging macht hängt natürlich immer mit
Entscheidungen zusammen die entweder
eine Person oder mehrere Personen ein
Kollektiv
trifft und die Entscheidungen verweisen
wieder auf Verantwortung also wer Macht
ausübt der hat immer natürlich auch
Verantwortung für das was er oder sie
tut wir können macht konkreter weiter
differenzieren es geht um
machttausübung und Machtübertragung in
repräsentativen Demokratien wird von den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
den Repräsentant Repräsentanten macht
übertragen jedoch nicht so wie bei
Thomas
horbes dort ist es der Fall dass alle
Mitglieder eines Staates ihre gesamte
Freiheit ihre gesamte Macht dem Staat
übertragen der dann eine mächtige Person
wird der leviatan so ist die
Machtübertragung sicherlich auch nicht
zu verstehen also repräsentative
Demokratie bedeutet nicht dass die
einzelnen Mitglieder eines Staates ganz
auf ihrem macht und ihre Freiheit
verzichten die Macht wird übertragen
durch
Wahl ist dann aber immer noch in einem
Verhältnis der Repräsentation also die
Interessen der wählerinen und Wähler
sollen durch die Machtübertragung gerade
verstärkt werden gewahrt werden und
nicht missbraucht werden oder nicht soll
die macht sich gegen die Interessen der
Wählerinnen und Wähler richten ganz
wichtig ist in demokratisch politischen
System Themen das Prinzip der
gewaltilung zwischen Legislative also
der gesetzgebenden der Judikative der
urteilenden und der Exekutive der
ausführenden Gewalt dadurch soll sowas
wie Gewalten Ballung macht Konzentration
vermieden werden natürlich
Machtkonzentration in der Regel auf eine
Person wir können natürlich sehen dass
es in der Geschichte der
politischen Systeme immer wieder
Diktaturen gab und gibt natürlich auch
sowas wie absolute Monarchien das ist
der klassische Fall wo eine einzige
Person der Monarch der Prinzeps der
prinipe um mit makavelli zu sprechen die
gesamte Staatsgewalt auf sich
vereint hier ist sicherlich der
Ausspruch von dem Sonnenkönig Ludwig dem
14 sehr zentral let semis der Staat das
bin ich l 14 hat also beansprucht die
gesamt te Staatsgewalt in seiner Person
zu vereinigen natürlich besteht darin
ein gravierender Nachteil eine
Problematik die man die
fürstenwillkür nennt Willkür im
schlechten Sinne die Person kann alles
tun was sie will sie ist niemandem
Rechenschaft schuldig und muss ihre
Entscheidung auch gar nicht wirklich
begründen und vielleicht reflektieren
sie kann das aus ein puren Impuls heraus
tun das ist
problematisch das heißt eine solche
machttausübung respektiert politischen
System die Grenzen die Freiheiten die
würde andere Person nicht das kann
häufig zu Ungerechtigkeit führen macht
sollte deswegen immer an das Ideal der
Gerechtigkeit gebunden sein hier sehen
wir noch mal ein Bild von Ludwig dem 14
diese stolze Pose die ja nichts anderes
als seine Macht symbolisieren soll na
dieser Stolz aufgestützte Arm die andere
Hand in der Hüfte die das Schwert auch
noch zeigt und betont ähm das ist ganz
klar fürstenwillkür hier schön
allegorisch vielleicht sogar auch fast
schon symbolisiert durch die ganzen
Szenerien die sich hier
dun wir wollen noch auf einen aktuellen
politischen Philosophen Eingehen auf
Jürgen habermaß wir waren schon in einer
anderen Sitzung auf ihn zu sprechen
gekommen da mache ich auch oben rechts
den Link rein jürgen habbermas hat auch
was interessantes gesagt zum ver von
Macht und Politik er spricht nämlich
davon dass es durchaus Zwänge geben kann
in politischen Systemen Demokratien von
Zwängen spricht er aber er sagt dass der
Zwang immer nur der Zwang des besseren
arguments sein darf es darf nur insofern
Zwänge geben im rationalen Diskurs er
spricht h vom Diskurs von der
kommunikativen Handlung es darf nur da
darin inoweit Zwänge geben als es sich
dabei um die Zwänge des besseren
arguments handelt es darf kein Zwang
sein der aufgrund von größerer
Stärke Kraft und Vermögen ausgeübt wird
sind es ist ein idealer intellektueller
Zwang der einfach in der besseren
Einsicht besteht natürlich setzt es
voraus dass jeweils das Gegenüber dieses
Argument auch akzeptiert als das bessere
und dann sich gezwungen fühlt und das
ist natürlich auch eine sehr große
Anforderung ein sehr ideales
idealistisches Modell von politischer
Macht Entwicklung macht die nur auf das
bessere Argument gestützt wird das kann
man sagen ist sehr idealistisch weil
häufig macht eben auch mit ganz anderen
Dingen zu tun hat mit individuellen
kollektiven Interessen die nicht der
Universalität der Einsicht oder
vielleicht auch der Logik politische
Systeme dient häufig haben verschiedene
Personen verschiedene Grundannahmen so
dass sie sich vielleicht gar nicht einig
werden können und sowas wie einen
rationalen Zwang empfinden können weil
sie dagegen immunisiert sind durch ihre
Ideologie und so weiter und so fort das
heißt das ist sehr voraussetzungsreich
und man muss sich fragen ob es
vielleicht nicht doch an der politischen
Realität vorbeigeht weil es die Probleme
zu wenig betrachtet die Irrationalitäten
die Rationalität die sich gerade so eine
universalen Logik entziehen und die doch
auch wirklich für politische Systeme
sehr wichtig ist sowas wie
Sophistik wo es darum geht die andere
Person nur zu überreden und nicht zu
überzeugen ja das muss man etwas
problematisieren man muss auch sagen
dass gerade in demokratischen
politischen Systemen immer mehr der
Politik unterstellt wird dass sie nur
machtinessen Volk Lobby Politik betreibt
das ist nur das Ziel sein Macht zu
erhalten oder gar weiter auszubauen und
nicht macht mit Gerechtigkeit zu
verbinden oft wird unterstellt dass es
nur um persönlichen Vorteil geht um
Geldgewinn man sieht das häufig auch bei
korrupten PolitikerInnen Politiker dass
das Wohl der Wähler missachtet wird ähm
und in parlamentarischen debatten wie
wir sie im Bundestag erleben da erlebt
man nur sehr selten diesen Zwang des
besseren arguments wie von Jürgen
habermß gefördert wird häufig wird
polemisiert und kritisiert und manchmal
auch
diffamiert breitzeiten werden abgegeben
die aber nichts mit dem Zwang des
rationalen arguments zu tun haben
deswegen kann man schon manchmal den
Eindruck erhalten dass es in der Politik
nur um Machterhalt und machtvergrößerung
geht und das ist eine große Gefahr die
dann zur Politik Verdrossenheit führt
die aber auch Tor und Tür für
Verschwörungstheorien und Ideologien
öffnen das war nur eine kurze
Problematisierung der aktuellen
demokratischen Systeme wenn sie nicht
genug auf Macht und Verantwortung
reflektieren bedanke mich für die
Aufmerksamkeit bis zu einer nächsten
Sendung